All right, let's get directly into
audience questions for the week.
First one is one I've gotten from a lot of
people. What happens to Donald Trump's adult
children once he's out of office? The answer
will depend on things we don't yet know.
We've talked about the possibility that some
of Trump's children might run for office.
We've talked about the possibility that Trump's
children or children in law would, for example,
run for Senate. As Laura Trump is reportedly
thinking about doing in North Carolina. They
may go back to private industry. They may be
really tied up with investigations for some
time. And that is why Donald Trump has reportedly
been considering preemptive pardons for them.
What we do know is that they're sort of reentry
into private life is not going to put them back
where they were before this entire presidential
fiasco. For example, in New York City,
wanted signs have been showing up for Ivanka
and Jared Kushner, except they say not wanted.
They are not. Welcome back in New York City.
And there have been some interesting articles
written about how they are not likely
to be sort of like re accepted into the
left leaning New York City social scene. I don't
feel bad for them at all, but it is interesting.
And recent news is that Jared and Ivanka
have recently purchased a multimillion dollar
actually report is thirty million dollar
plot of land somewhere in Florida to build
some kind of estate. So I think that how this
all shakes out is not going to be known until
we see the full resolution of how Donald
Trump is ultimately going to sort of go out.
Is he going to eventually concede and attend
Joe Biden's inauguration and act like an adult?
Is he going to go tomorrow, logo for Christmas
and never come back to the White House and not
attend the inauguration?
And then subsequently,
how tied up will Donald Trump, his family and his
businesses be on the basis of investigations? It's
not just the Southern District of New York that
is reportedly preparing a number of different
investigations into possible wrongdoing by Trump
and his family. There are other investigators
and and state prosecutors as well. So I think
we're simply not going to know now. The other
possibility that's been floated is that the future
of Trump's children is in media as media hosts. To
be perfectly frank, I see that is very unlikely.
I think if the future of the Trump family is in
media, it would be this idea of Trump starting
some kind of media outlet, an alternative to Fox
News, more in the line of the conspiratorial
rantings of outlets like Newsmax and so on.
But it's really unclear whether Trump
actually has the appetite for that.
And it's really not clear that Trump is
going to have the appetite. I mean, listen,
when narcissists lose, it is very demoralizing
and they always come up with some excuse,
right. Trump will rationalize his loss with it was
rigged and stolen. Plus, I had the pandemic, which
was just a timing thing. And if it weren't for the
pandemic, I definitely would have won. He every
narcissist with delusions of grandeur will not
rationalize losing so that it's not really losing,
but it can often completely take the wind
out of their sales. And listen, Trump, 74,
and it looks like he you know, he moved his
legal residence from New York to Florida, that
Florida there's every indication that
he's going to be doing a lot of golfing.
We may not see him do much. And it's
possible his kids won't do that much either.
It's very tough to tell. We will follow it and we
will we will know more before before you know it.